on l'entend souvent avant des
conférences de presse des annonces du
gouvernement ou des événements
comme
la reconnaissance du territoire de
certains traités ça fait partie de
l'histoire canadienne micron bien savent
c'est quoi un traité exactement on vous
explique cela les traités sont des
ententes conclues en la couronne
aujourd'hui les gouvernements canadien
et les groupes autochtones qui
définissent les droits et obligations de
tous les partis pour coexister et
partager les terres des premières
nations mais à la base les pratiques
constituaient des actes de cession de
terres à une très grande échelle le
gouvernement du canada cannes à 70 ans
traité historique signé 2701 à 1923 il y
a plusieurs cd traité dont les traités
historiques les traités moderne et
litres étaient numérotés
les onze très ténu mais rate et couvre
une grande partie du pays du nord ouest
de l'ontario jusqu'au orageuses et la
mer beaufort ou du conte les territoires
des traités 6 7 et 8 couvre la majorité
de la région connue comme l'alberta
aujourd'hui voici les grandes lignes de
chacun
les traits this is a été signé en 1876
mais des signatures additionnels ont été
ajoutés dans les années suivantes une
cinquantaine des nations unies et un
client les peuples crise photo na
coûteux et dénis parmi les promesses
pour les encourager à signer des
médicaments et soins de santé de
l'aidant temps de famine et l'éducation
gratuites
le traité 7 a été signé en 1877 par cinq
nations can à six coeurs pick and in
nakhooda et tout ina les signataires de
ce traité souhaitait axer l'entente sur
l'élevage du bétail afin de faire face à
la diminution de la population de bison
une autre différence importante
on ne promet pas d'école dans les
réserves ont garanti seulement que le
gouvernement paiera les salaires des
enseignants
le traité numéro 8 lui ont été
officialisées en 1899 plus de huit cent
quarante mille kilomètres carrés de
terres ont été cédés avec ce traité un
ajout important de se traiter les
personnes qui choisissent de vivre à
l'extérieur des réserves avaient droit
chacun à 160 offres ses terres en
propriété individuelle est une réponse
au fait que la densité des populations
n'étaient pas aussi importante dans le
nord
les traités ont été essentiels à la
création du pays mais de nombreuses des
promesses faites à l'époque n'ont pas
été tenues la reconnaissance et
territoires des traités est une façon de
se rappeler cette histoire et honorer
les peuples autochtones qui étaient les
premiers à vivre sur ses terres
[Musique]